i did my time i was fortunate to come
back from that
and my expectation was you know that i
would just live a long
healthy life with my family right now at
six
thousands of american soldiers have died
fighting in wars overseas but
many more get home safe only to get sick
when they return
now that's a story getting a lot of
national attention and our i-team has
been looking into it for months now
some doctors say burn pits full of toxic
chemicals
are causing our men and women in uniform
to develop cancer
the i-team's david sharon is here now
with one veteran's story
david denise imagine being deployed to
afghanistan and survive
only to come home and then develop
life-threatening cancer
it happened to one henderson veteran
who's bravely served his country twice
but is now fighting a whole different
kind of battle
your concern is obviously the needs of
the mission and less so like
that you're thinking about those after
effects matthew wetnall has made a lot
of sacrifices for our country
i missed my first time being born he
enlisted at 26
serving eight years in active duty
getting married and joining the reserves
i wanted to do something you know
contribute or you know i wanted to kind
of be a part
and have a story for my kids those
stories to share with trevor
and liam include two tours in
afghanistan a year as a ford observer
and then a year in combat even surviving
an ied blast
it gave me the maturity and the
perspective i needed in life to
kind of set myself where i want to be
and what i want to do with my family
but it also may have given him cancer
the evidence suggests that it's probably
my time in the service
in march years of relentless headaches
for this non-smoker proved
too much i've lived in quite a bit of
pain for probably
a little over 10 years these scans show
what doctors found
a golf ball-sized mass on the back of
his brain another on his lung
and he believes it started overseas not
from any violence
but from the air i certainly would never
have expected or hoped for this
wetnall says the safest and most
efficient way to get rid of trash at war
is in a burn pit but those burning
batteries mortal rounds
jet fuel even human waste give off toxic
fumes
lethal smoke evidence shows is sickening
america's brave
trash was lit on fire with jet fuel jp8
which contains benzene a carcinogen dr
anthony sema is studying burn pit's
effects on the lungs
he testified before congress about it
earlier this year
it should not be a controversial issue
it
is perhaps because it is a financial
issue
sema is one of few doctors who will go
on the record
putting burn pits and cancer together
and he has good reason
his research found chemical compounds
from those burning piles of trash
in our veterans lungs at least in our
samples
from these patients we've definitely
seen that he equates it to what happened
to rescuers at ground zero
months of working on a burning mound of
metal and dust
leading to cases of cancer among 9 11
first responders
i think there's a failure of anybody
that could be affected by this
just like that battle in the middle east
there's no
giving up here but getting help from the
federal government is proving to be
a new kind of warfare the department of
veterans affairs says
it is studying burn pits and potential
long-term health effects
but right now the agency doesn't
acknowledge a connection
and organizing and structuring every bit
of detail that i need
to know who can help the family's
kitchen table
now the command center for this whole
new conflict
my priority is you know longevity i want
to be here for my family and
you know we have plans and i have a life
that i want to be a part of
now the va did not respond to our
requests for an interview for the story
they didn't answer me at all
the department does have a registry for
service members to join
if they think they were exposed to these
toxins in those burn pits
but says in a handout quote many health
conditions related to these hazards are
temporary
and should disappear after the exposure
ends now no doctor has yet to say
whetnall's cancer is definitely
connected to the burn pits but he and so
many others
are fighting for that acknowledgment i'm
david charns 8 news now